we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie
marvel released a new spider-man no way
home imax trailer with some extra
details in the footage we didn't see in
the previous trailer there's been all
kinds of new tobey maguire and andrew
garfield spider-man details that have
come out so we figured it's a great time
to do a new easter eggs video and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
going to be a lot of spider-man related
stuff happening in the next six months
or so between all the different
spider-man movies that are coming out
but you've all probably watched the
spiderman no way home trailer a billion
times there's some really obvious tobey
mcguire spider-man and andrew garfield
references in the trailer and some
hidden details and references too some
of the scenes marvel and sony chopped up
in the trailer to hide what's actually
going on and some of the scenes are just
so darkly lit that you need to crank up
the brightness all the way up to 100
just to see the background details like
inside the basement of the sanctum where
it kind of seems like doctor strange is
keeping sinister six characters from the
multiverse prisoner like some kind of
crazy magical guantanamo bay also thanks
to this new imax version of the trailer
with the expanded footage and details
that we get you can actually see that
this person here is not matt murdock's
daredevil character charlie cox is like
see you can clearly see these are not my
forearms in the previous trailer a lot
of people had just theorized that maybe
matt murdock helps him out at some point
during one of these scenes it's possible
that he's still in the movie somewhere
just not in this particular scene but
we'll start with the bigger more obvious
easter eggs and references then talk
about the newer hidden details that
we've gotten some more information about
recently yes i know that everyone is
still talking about this special effects
scene of andrew garfield spider-man that
people claim is from the movie
apparently there was a d fake artist
that used a picture of this the andrew
garfield spider-man blue screen and
animated it then admitted that it was
fake but then supposedly recanted that
part and said that it wasn't fake like
the picture itself that he used to make
the deep fake animation was not fake
just the animation so i wouldn't worry
too much about that the reason why it
doesn't matter whether or not this scene
is real or not is because the whole
point is that we all believe that andrew
garfield is in the movie so i think the
takeaway from this particular scene here
is you know who cares it might not be a
scene in the movie but andrew garfield
spider-man is in the movie also if there
were actual like really big leaks like
this sony would have taken them down for
copyright immediately when they first
happened they have an army of people
dedicated to protecting against huge
leaks like this if you remember when
avengers end game leaked out on youtube
the week before the movie came out
marvel flipped but in the trailer we can
clearly see at least five of the
original core sinister six characters
there's the very obvious alfred molina
doctor octopus because he literally
steps out onto this big bridge fight
scene and greets peter hello peter i
will explain in a second why he knows
who tom holland's peter parker is and
this is the part of the movie that sam
raimi commented on he just said that he
thought that it was beautiful that they
brought alfred molina's character back
it talked a little bit about the way
they were changing the special effects
for his octopus arms saying that when
they made spider-man 2 they used
puppetry to do all of his arms they're
using a lot of digital effects to de-age
alfred molina a little bit because he is
almost 20 years older so they want him
to look almost exactly like he did
during spider-man 2. one of the more
subtle easter eggs or not subtle easter
eggs for tobey maguire that you probably
also noticed during this big bridge
fight scene is that when he's standing
on the car and he gets ready to put on
the iron spider suit after the scene
where dr octopus says hello peter tom
holland's spider-man is wearing almost
the exact same suit that toby maguire
spider-man wore during his movies that's
why a lot of people think that there's
some trickery going on in this scene
like maybe this really isn't tom holland
maybe this is a fake scene and it's
actually toby mcguire standing here i
don't totally think that's the case but
i do believe that some of these scenes
have been faked just a little bit then
there's willem dafoe's green goblin
because of the goblin bombs and his
cackle there are also a lot of people
that claim that these are pictures of
him from the actual movie itself i don't
know if that's true or not but the great
thing about willem dafoe is that if you
look at him now and you look at him
during the events of the original
spider-man movies it doesn't look like
he's aged a day like he looks almost
exactly the same then there's jamie
foxx's electro he was announced a long
time ago and made all those posts on his
instagram account so we knew he was
going to be in the movie but now you can
see his yellow lightning twice during
the trailer the reason why it's yellow
is just because they're making him look
more comic book accurate during this
movie but it is meant to be his version
of electro from the amazing spider-man
2. also during this particular electro
scene you can see what looks like
sandman rising up from the ground with a
giant face forming in the dust cloud
here i also kind of think the black and
gold suit that you see spider-man
wearing here in the bottom corner of the
frame during this fight is like the mcu
version of the anti-shock suit just
based on the way it seems like he's
using it during these scenes they make
perfect replica toys like this hot toys
design which gives us a way better look
at the actual suit itself notice all the
circuitry weaved around it mixed with
what seems like dr strange's magical
artifacts is gauntlets like he's wearing
doctor strange magic gauntlets this blue
effect is meant to represent him using
magical energy for shields and for his
webbing like him creating a shield that
looks similar to the one doctor strange
used in avengers infinity war but blue
and whatever's going on with his webbing
here it just seems like it's magic
enhanced webbing then the fifth sinister
six character is the less visible what
seems like lizard here in this doctor
strange dungeon scene like you see a
hand reach out and try to claw him if
you tune up the picture just a little
bit it does seem like a lizard hand
trying to swipe him and in a separate
scene when he's running through the fee
shelter and rips his mask off chasing
one of the villains down if you look at
his chest it looks like it's got big
claw marks in it like lizard claw marks
across the chest there was supposedly a
behind the scenes picture of this
basement scene that more clearly
highlighted all the cells that leaked
out i'm not going to put it in this
video just for copyright reasons sony
probably would take it down but it just
confirms what we all saw in the previous
trailers but basic timeline for the
movie the way it seems like it goes down
is that first he comes to doctor strange
to make the one more day request please
make everyone forget that i'm spider-man
that goes completely wrong with
unintended consequences bringing the
multiverse sinister six villains from
the tobey maguire spider-man movies in
the andrew garfield spider-man movies
and at some point doctor strange just
captures these sinister six villains and
contains them in these magical prison
cells where we get to the bridge fight
scene where it seems like he's fighting
multiple sinister six felons like you
have the doctor octopus fight but you
also have the goblin bombs clearly they
have to escape at some point we see
spider-man fighting doctor strange for
that magic box with the special sigils
on it the symbol on the box is the same
symbol of agamotto the pattern that you
can see on the eye of agamotto amulet
which he's wearing again and the symbol
is also part of the sigil on all the
sanctums in the window here they
explained in the first dr strange movie
that the sigil is part of the
enchantment that protects this main mcu
reality in combination with the other
sanctums it acts as a barrier a shield
against beings like dormammu or
schumacher from other dimensions the
fact that it's on the box and spider-man
seems like he wants to open the box
makes it sound like the box contains the
key to these other universes in
spider-man thinks that for whatever
reason opening it will make everything
go back to the way it used to be of
course that probably only makes things
worse and it seems like the sinister six
villains just take advantage of that
using that as an opportunity to escape
but even though we don't see him in the
trailer here michael keaton's vulture
would be the sixth og member of the
classic sinister six but one of the
reasons why they're using so many of
them in this trailer even if they're not
all big characters in the movie maybe
some of them are just smaller cameos it
was a reveal that sony is wanting to do
a new sinister six solo movie franchise
off by itself like do spider-man sequels
like spider-man 4 but also separately do
sinister 6 movies you may remember they
tried to do the exact same thing during
the andrew garfield amazing spider-man
era andrew garfield himself said that
that would have been really cool they
did have some cool plans that was what
the whole amazing spider-man 2
post-credits scene was meant to set up
that they were gonna do the sinister six
team in a spin-off movie but i know on
top of all these easter eggs there are
all kinds of theories that marvel is
messing with the trailer footage faking
some scenes like they did with the
avengers infinity war trailer and the
avengers end game trailers so that
people don't actually know what's going
on like a lot of stuff in these trailers
could be totally fake but with that
being said based on all the new details
it seems like we're just getting a
little andrew garfield spider-man in the
tiniest smallest cameo scene from tobey
maguire just right now based on everyone
hunting down toby maguire for pictures
the past six months it seems like he's
probably only going to have a very short
scene probably at the end of the movie
and without more evidence i do not think
that we're gonna see him wearing his
spider-man costume even though that
would be really cool in notwithstanding
all the recent andrew garfield amazing
spider-man supposedly leaks i think that
at some point in the movie we will see
him in his spider-man costume in a more
active role than toby maguire's
spider-man so just be sure to temper
your expectations accordingly if you
think you've spotted any more tobey
maguire or andrew garfield's spider-man
references during the trailer footage
just write it below in the comments
we're going to get a new trailer pretty
soon and in that trailer there'll
probably be even more easter eggs and
references to their spider-man movies
and i know there's all kinds of rumors
about the venom let there be carnage
post-credits scene in spider-man
crossover the movie is out on thursday
so i will do my full post credit scene
video either thursday night or friday
morning and you won't have to wait that
long to find out what's actually going
on yes tom hardy was wearing a
spider-man no way home crew hat and they
only give those to people who worked on
the movie but i think that somebody just
gave him that he's not a huge character
in the movie maybe maybe at best we have
a small post-credit scene reference
hinting at spider-man and venom
crossover eventually but that's probably
gonna be it for venom in this movie my
full marvel what if episode 8 video will
post on wednesday just like normal it's
for the version of ultron that winds up
getting all six infinity stones everyone
click here for my brand new marvel
eternals trailer video and click here
for my what if video all about the
infinity gauntlet version of ultron
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you